bonsoir bienvenue à ce débat des chefs
un dernier rendez vous devant les
caméras une dernière chance pour les
chefs se faire bonne impression à dix
jours du vote
premier thème environnement et énergie
c'est l'environnement et l'énergie qui
lance la discussion
derrière le ton prudent les premières
lignes d'attaqué jedessine tenir tête
contre jason kenny contre les
pétrolières contre d'oxford contre ces
politiciens conservateurs qui ne veulent
rien faire pour l'environnement une
façon d'ébranler les convictions des
électeurs tentés par le bloc québécois
elisabeth mais elles soulignent
l'urgence de la situation en citant la
jeune greta tout berck il n'y a personne
avec un plan qui marche pour éviter le
pire contact anne bragard raison notre
maison est en feu
comment osez-vous l'idée d'un oléoduc
est-ouest revient rapidement sur la
sellette
ici ces messieurs pipeline issime ces
messieurs pipeline encore et monsieur
trudeau je pense aussi si monsieur
pipeline
moi je suis jack médecin si je vais
jamais imposé un pipeline sur le québec
c'est l'économie qui donne lieu aux
premiers échanges plus musclée on avait
tellement d'ambition pour les
investissements les baisses d'impôts
pour la classe moyenne mais non monsieur
on n'a pas baissé les impôts des plus
riches
vous promettez une baisse d'impôt de 50
mille dollars
misty millionnaire je vous avez menti
quand les premières à sortir l'histoire
vous avez menti quand vous avez dit que
j'aurais pensé écrit cherchiez-vous
montée en national et les plaines et
pour faire en sorte la seule promesse
que chez vous l'avez dit c'est des
coupures
on peut couper les subventions aux
entreprises absent des débats jusqu'ici
la question des services en français
hors québec est soulevée par ce
francophone de mississauga vivre dans
une minorité est un défi alors que le
chef bloquiste en la main aux autres
provinces
il faut que les francophones au canada
et les acadiens et le même niveau
service que les anglais du québec justin
trudeau saisi l'occasion pour brandir le
spectre de d'oxford une troisième
référence au premier ministre ontarien
dans ce débat vous souvienne
et comme moi longtemps de ce que
monsieur ford a fait 2 qui est venu au
pouvoir
nouvelle réponse elle cette fois sous le
thème de l'immigration
le bloc québécois devient la cible des
tirs groupés des autres chefs avec
plusieurs députés bloquistes
on ne peut pas faire parce que justin
trudeau va rester comme première cible
voter pour le bloc c'est voter pour les
libéraux à voter pour le bloc c'est
voter pour les conservateurs voter pour
le bloc
c'est vrai pour le québec mashal un peu
parce que oui le bloc c'est vous mais le
québec c'est une diversité maintenant
que le bloc veut reprendre une place et
vous et les québécois encore une fois à
l'opposition inutile de vous dire qu'on
a reçu une tonne de questions sur la
laïcité est difficile d'imaginer un
dernier débat sans que la laïcité ne
s'invite pressé d'offrir plus de clarté
les chefs s'en sont tenus aux positions
qu'ils avancent depuis le début de cette
campagne
je ne veux pas intervenir il y en pour
suite je ne veux pas intervenir
ce que je veux faire c'est de gagner le
coeur des gens monsieur 5 odile
contraire de ce qu'avait dit en anglais
récemment eu une possibilité d'une
intervention éventuelle mais c'est pas
garanti monsieur bernier parce que nous
allons laisser les étapes suivent leur
cours pour les québécois la notion de
laïcité c'est une valeurs progressistes
la sphère snc lavalin s'est finalement
émis c'est à la toute fin de la joute
sans surprise seul justin trudeau et
françois blanchet se disent d'accord
avec l'idée d'un accord de réparation un
débat plus disciplinés sans grands
moments de passion mais qui aura au
moins permis aux téléspectateurs
d'entendre clairement les points de vue
des chefs
et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa